vous savez pour nous vous êtes une
énigme on a cherché votre visage et vos
empreintes dans toutes nos bases de
données et qu'est-ce qu'on a trouvé rien
alors si on commençait par votre nom 47
c'est pas un nom non mais c'est le
mien vous n'avez aucune raison d'avoir
confiance en moi mais vous êtes en
danger qu'est-ce que je dois faire
fuyz vite vite
allez
[Musique]
attention vous savez pourquoi vous êtes
encore
en parce que j'ai choisi de ne pas vous
tuer mais mais eux ils le feront vous
vous rappelez le jour de votre
enlèvement on faisait partie du même
programme ils veulent ce qu'il y a dans
notre ADN la
vitesse
l'intelligence la
force d'accord détachez-moi vous êtes
comme
moi alors
débrouillez-vous
dites-moi comment on fabrique un agent
vous ne voulez pas d'
agent vous voulez une
armée ils sont la clé de
tout non seulement vous êtes doué pour
survivre mais vous voyez
toutz
[Musique]
ce programme on va le réduire en
Sendre vous savez qui je
[Musique]
suis